all right welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
unmute and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in q and a session at
the end
second today's gdpr seminar is open to
external audiences and therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out finally the talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
youtube channel that's about it now let
me introduce our speaker today
it is an honor to host ben erickson who
is an assistant professor for
data-driven modeling and artificial
intelligence in the department of
mechanical engineering and material
science at the university of pittsburgh
before joining university of pittsburgh
he was a postdoctoral researcher in the
department of statistics at uc berkeley
where he worked with michael mahoney
he was also a postdoc at the department
of applied mathematics at the university
of washington
um working with nathan cruz and stephen
brunson he earned his phd in statistics
at the university of saint andrews
ben's work is broadly interested at the
intersection of deep learning dynamical
systems and robustness
he is also interested in leveraging
tools from randomized numerical linear
algebra to build modern algorithms for
data intensive applications such as
fluid flows and climate science today
then we'll talk about
continuous networks for sequential uh
predictions which is very interesting
topics so please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk
now without further ado let me pass the
button to ben by asking one random
question as usual
this random question is i guess it's not
random it's these days the same question
okay what is your favorite things to do
other than research
oh okay
i think i'm a passionate skier
i do ski racing so
yeah
is there a city area in you know near
the school well there is um i i actually
been out this winter in some valley
idaho because i
i didn't have to teach but there's some
some smaller ski resorts down here it's
called seven springs
i think which is about an hour south of
pittsburgh well i i'm the beginner of
the ski uh in the ski
i guess i i better learn from yoga you
and all right
okay perfect thank you so much for for
the introduction i'm very glad to be
here
and
to talk a bit about my recent research
on continuous networks for sequential
predictions and that's a joint work with
um
liam
alejandro sonju and omri and michael
mahoney
so let me start with giving you a little
bit um
a game plan for today's talks i start
with a brief introduction and then i um
kind of briefly talk about ode nets so
just that we have all the same pickup
point
and then switch to
kind of the discussion of continuous
time recurrent neural networks in
particular i will discuss three
different formulations like lipsticks
recurrent neural networks
and then noisy iron ends and our latest
work
lengths long expressive memory
i will not probably get to dynamic auto
encoders um
since since i just have roughly an hour
um so yeah so the main talk will be will
be focused or centered around for
current neural networks
um
i assume you're all all very um aware of
um what um sequence modeling involves
right where we try to map an input
sequence to a target sequence but there
are many different variations to this
problem
so it's the simplest case we just want
to have a single input which will map
to a single
target
and then we have the other situation
where we try to map a sequence to a
single target
or just a single input to a sequence or
like i think the most challenging um
problem set up is that we want to map a
sequence to a sequence
um
in in general these problems can become
very
challenging if we deal with like
[Music]
data from
some dynamic systems which feature
rich multiscale and nonlinear temporal
structure
examples might be turbulent flows or
some climate data
but we have also this prediction if we
have basically tried to analyze video
streams which are recorded by a
self-driving car
there are many classical models for
sequential predictions
the simplest one are probably linear
models or exponential smoothing a reamer
these problems are
very robust actually
[Music]
and by robust i mean they have low
variations
they don't give you a crazy
a crazy prediction
sorry for that
[Music]
and um but but the main challenge is
that these problems do not really scale
to high dimensional
data so assume like you try to to model
a fluid flow which has maybe
which is typically very high dimensional
or some climate data and they also
obviously struggle with modeling very
complex non-linear dynamics
so neural networks
are known for for
known for being able to handle very high
dimensional data so there's no surprise
that there are many neural network based
techniques for sequential
predictions
and
one of the classic
frame or architectures for this task our
recurrent neural networks and um it's
many variants like gated recurrent
neural networks lstms and so on
more recently there's a lot of interest
in transformers
which have like um basically shown great
success for natural language processing
but they are also now used in all kinds
of uh related domains
and there are also very interesting
other techniques like cause a temporal
convolutional networks
but in this talk again i will mainly
talk about uh recurrent neural networks
um
so one of the main issues of these
i don't want to say traditional neural
network techniques is um that they're
quite often a little bit brittle and
prone to fail um so they're not very
robust and they give you very good point
predictions but they can also
failed dramatically and that's an issue
if these models are used in
mission-critical applications such as
self-driving cars
hey ben i'm sorry to interrupt but you
know on the title area there's just some
you know
uh what is the firefox symbol and the
video symbol is you can can you move
that
away um
okay
is it possible to move that
if not don't worry about it i mean it's
just
um covering someone yeah i don't know
what what do you see now i see the uh oh
i see the yes i scream i i'm not uh sure
oh yeah i see that's an issue um
if you can move that's that that'll be a
wonderful but if you cannot let's not
worry about it like i'm not able to move
it uh interesting
sorry for that don't worry
yeah okay um
right above the title um
[Music]
okay so so one one idea to to tackle
this problem is like to better
understand like what is going on in in
neural networks in
these black box architectures and what
you can do is like to break them into
simpler building blocks that you then
can study
and i'm particularly interested in
studying neural networks or simpler
building blocks through the lens of
dynamical systems
so you
you can view
neural networks as a dynamical system
and if you do that then you can actually
port a lot of interesting theory
from the dynamic assistance community
over to um
[Music]
to machine learning to deep learning and
try to understand better what is going
on
um so
kind of this is slightly different than
just applying machine learning to a
dynamic assistant problem
um
[Music]
and
kind of what what are the connections at
a high level for instance and i will
talk a bit more about this later it's
like there's like a rich connection
between different network architecture
textures and numerical methods and you
can build a connection between
different training schemes and stability
and control theory
so i will show a bit in this talk how
how some of these ideas help us to
better understand what is going on
okay um let me talk a bit about ode nets
um
it keeps us really really brief um
but
just so that we are all on the same page
i assume you're all
familiar with
[Music]
an
ode initial value problem
but in in many situations
we don't know the right hand side so
we can't explicitly formulate um what f
is so the best we can do is collect some
observational data
and then the idea of an ode net is to
approximate the right hand side using a
neural network
given some data and
you can here kind of plug in
your favorite neural networks it can be
a fully connected neural network or
some convolutional neural network so
depending on the problem whatever works
best
okay
so what do we get from this formulation
i mean first of all
if i formulate it in continuous time i
cannot train it
because at the end if i want to train it
i need some some just a discrete form uh
so that i can build a computational
graph
um but like from theoretical point of
view i can um
kind of study some some of the behaviors
of such a neural network which has been
done recently very successfully
and kind of this view is actually not
new if you go back
in time and look to early work by
rosenblatt
he formulated already
networks
neural networks in continuous time and
then
rico martinez has kind of
proposed this formulation but it got
really popularized just recently by
by shen
who got like a
best nerfs
paper award for his paper on neural
odes
okay so basically in order to train it
we need to discretize the model and
well we can
just look into our textbooks
on numerical analysis and pick some
numerical integration scheme right so
the simplest
scheme we can pick would be an euler
discretization and you see now
immediately it's a resemblance to a rest
net
but we can also show some more
interesting integration schemes like uh
arca for classic
and that would kind of if you look to
the connection this would um looks very
similar to a dense net
um
and
kind of the difference is like that in a
rest net we have to evaluate like our um
neural network block only once where in
an arc of four
uh scheme we would not
need like four evaluations so it's more
computationally
expensive to train
a network with a scheme but i'll show
you in a second that it in some
situation has some advantages
i do that i just want to make you aware
that kind of this view is um
at some point like we have to be a bit
caution here right because numerical
integration works in a different
direction and
learning the dynamics using a neural
network so numerical integration
typically we start with a known f
and then we discretize it and then we
generate some data
what i'm proposing here with neural odes
is we are given some data
and then we minimize some loss function
let's say like the mean squared error
and we hope we get a good approximate
obvious
model r which is a good approximation
for this unknown f
um
and that is what we see typically or
quite often not the case in particular
not if you use
the forward euler integration okay
here's a question i guess
you can also train it with a joint
sensitivity mess and it's like
okay yeah that's that's a um it's a good
good hint from uh robert
um
i haven't looked into into that um
[Music]
um into that but yeah very interesting
so okay so robert
commented that you can also train it
with a add strong sensitivity methods
like with
c
v o d es
down here at lnl in the case you are
still doing everything in the continuous
method but you are only using the
backdrop for the objective error at each
integration point i i just read it
for the folks who will watch this
youtube video later for sure not have a
access to the chat to kind of expand on
that you can actually
specify just a standard adjoint
sensitivity optimization which is done
with some software packages here but in
that case um what you need to do is you
have some goal function which is like
the l2 norm of the error
between
like what you're outputting and what the
training data is
and then your
all you need is the back propagation for
your local neural network inside the i
joint sensitivity to properly
differentiate the goal of the l2 error
at that integration point so you end up
not needing to take a bunch of time
steps you can use adaptive time stepping
for the whole thing
i see okay that's that's interesting so
i i might ask you a follow-up question
but let me go with a slide because sure
um what what we saw it's like okay what
surprised us a little bit um
is um originally like a sec and what
quite often um you read now in the
literature is that a resnet is actually
just a forward euler discretization but
what we see in practice is that um
kind of this forward or discretization
of a network behaves different than what
we would expect if it were an actual
fault with a discretization so what do i
mean by that so let's look like at a
very simple um
dynamical system just a non-linear
pendulum
and
so we
generate some ground truth data which is
shown here in
by these
blue squares
okay so if you use um the forward euler
discretization and
don't make the
time step too small then we know a
forward euler will diverge if we use a
numerical integrator but what happens if
we use the neural network
discretized with forward euler it
basically fits the data perfectly fine
um similar with archer iv okay
so it seems like um the forward oil
discretization is learning
through the integration integration
scheme and
provides us with good accurate point
prediction
but if
like the function we have learned would
were meaningful that means like during
inference time we should be able to
change like
the delta t
or delta t and kind of go be able to go
smaller time steps
and if we do this we see like this
conversion plot on the right hand side
and if you look to the red line here
that's for the
[Music]
euler ode net we see like if we slightly
change delta t during inference time
then the error increases
and that is not consistent with um with
theory
uh from numerical analysis where we
would expect like for forward euler that
the error is decreasing if we decrease
delta t
but if you train a neural network with
archer 4
then we see like that we have the right
behavior that if we
decrease delta t the error
during inference time has also decreased
so
um it
kind of
matters how we discretize the neural
network if we want for instance and use
this model to interpolate points between
two two points we have observed
using just forward euler did not work we
tried other time stepping methods and um
on this problem he has a different
schemes
and they didn't they didn't do too well
but it's a bit different a bit
challenging to do this conversion
analysis with those models
but the point is we have to be very
careful how we train a neural network if
we want to use it for scientific
applications
particularly if you want to later
interpolate data or extrapolate data and
not just simply predict
a single
target given a single input
and if you're more interested about this
i don't want to draw too much on this
topic
but we have recently posted a paper on
learning continuous models for
continuous physics
which exactly discusses this issue
okay good
so this was like just a brief overview
of what i mean by um
an ode net and um how i think about like
a continuous time formulation of a
neural network obviously there's a lot
of exciting work going on so now i take
this view and apply it to recurrent
neural networks
but if you have any questions i can
pause for for a second
do you do you have any challenge you
know training the
you know ode nets
um
so so it depends what what your task is
so if again if i just want to get a good
point prediction they're very easy to to
train right this is a very simple
networks i mean obviously it depends a
bit on on the problem
um you're looking at but um they're
they're easy to train even i mean we
just use backprop
um
see the the challenge is like to learn a
meaningful approximation
of
the right-hand side of a differential
equation right so but meaningful i i
mean like that i'm able doing inference
time to interpolate points in between
data that i have observed that i can
make delta t or my time step smaller or
larger so that that is like
indeed a bit tricky you have to be
careful but using higher order
integrator schemes help us to to learn a
meaningful approximation for the
continuous dynamics
how about the large uh system of odes
like you you have many many variables
yep
we have it works as well we have we have
um applied it to to some um
fluid flows um
basically you can plug in like this
framework or combine it with an auto
encoder or an auto encoder um
architecture
um where you first learn an embedding
and then basically learn the dynamics um
in the middle to to evolve the system so
um of course like it's a problem it gets
gets larger i mean you you have you it
is challenging but um
we get good results yeah so it's pretty
promising
very good thank you ben okay
perfect um okay let me switch to
recurrent neural networks
um they have somewhat a bad reputation
for for some reason um
mainly um i think there was like up to
probably five six years it was somewhat
challenging to to train the current
neural networks
because they have some stability issues
um
but
i will show like that kind of this
problem um
can can can be solved
and now i think modern modern recurrent
network architectures um achieve
state-of-the-art performance and quite
often outperform lstms and in some cases
even transformers if you have very
[Music]
uh basically very long um
sequences you deal with because in in
those situation a transformer is just
not feasible
um so just as a reminder
what is a recurrent unit it's like a
very simple architecture actually
so we
here's a difference to to a standard
feed forward neural network is that we
basically have some feedback connection
or some form of a memory
by learning a hidden state age
and what we do at every
update step or iteration in our model we
we update h by using this update
function on the right hand side
where we basically have a w which is a
hidden to hidden matrix
and we have in addition like an input to
hidden matrix which takes like the
current input at time t
and then you have a bias term
and
we just wrap around some non-linearity
typically we use a ton h function here
but there are some other versions of
nonlinear functions that you can use as
well
depending on on the problem and you can
expense this of course i mean instead of
just having an input to hidden matrix
you can put here some
some
encoder which is like nonlinear
um
but
that is a simple basic recurrent unit
which i don't know i think probably um
it's like got popularized in in the late
80s
so it's around for a while
okay but the problem is like just assume
it we have like a linear
discrete time dynamical systems and
you're well aware right i mean that
we we can have like an issue of um
that that the dynamics either vanish or
explode depending on the eigenvalues of
this linear map
um
a and um
in an opt or kind of at least for for
learning the problem is like if or if
the dynamics um
um quickly converge
then um we have um during trainings and
this leads to a vanishing gradient
problem on the other hand side if the
dynamics
um explode or sorry
diverge then this leads to an exploding
gradient problem during training so
sometimes during training we would like
a model
which is on the edge of chaos that means
like for a linear model we won't have
eigenvalues on the unit circle
okay but
our
current neural network is not linear
it's non-linear so kind of the analysis
is a bit a bit more challenging than
just computing or looking at the
eigenvalues
of this model
um i
switch over this model so doing this
analysis in discrete time can become um
really challenging in particular if you
consider an additional some gates or
some more modern variants
and it's actually much nicer if you um
consider
a continuous time formulation of a
current network as i do here in equation
four
so a simple idea here is like if you
formulate it in continuous time and you
want to check
whether
your model is
stable or or not or in whichever gene it
is you can
compute the jacobian
and then
you get some local analysis for for
stability by checking the eigenvalues of
the jacobian
so one idea here which has been proposed
like called the antisymmetric rn
would be then from this analysis to
consider an anti-symmetric matrix for w
um which basically um leads to to a
matrix that
has only eigenvalues that are imaginary
so you can show like this
model
[Music]
neither has a diverging
nor converging dynamics so it is on the
edge of chaos
and it does not has like these these
issues of exploding or vanishing
gradients
uh in practice it turns out this is a
little bit too restrictive
um and also that provides the owner with
a with a local analysis
so what we tried to do in our lips
recurrent neural networks is to come up
with some global analysis
and to do that we had to slightly change
the architecture
basically we introduce this additional
linear term
um in in front of the nonlinear term so
we have like now um a unit which is um
designed by like a linear component plus
a literal sonarity
and
again we just assume here that
this non-linearity or
is like an m lipschitz function
and if we if we do this then we can
use some nice results
from control theory
to to study like
basically the properties and show that
this particular recurrent unit is
globally exponentially stable under some
mild condition on
the
hidden to hidden matrix a and w
in in particular what we require is um
that
the eigenvalues of the symmetric part of
a
of a sum are strictly negative
and that w is
non-singular um and then we also need to
ensure that the um
the smallest
singular value of asymmetric is larger
than
the
largest singular value of w
okay so if we can satisfy this condition
then our current unit is globally
exponentially stable
so knowing this that helps us now to
divide to define like some scheme to
design
a and w in a way so that we basically
can
satisfy
these conditions
and the idea is basically by using a
symmetric skew decomposition for
constructing these hidden matrices
so we design like some matrix s or some
weight matrix s
as a convex combination of
a symmetric matrix and an anti-symmetric
matrix and in addition we have like this
term gamma i which allows us to shift
the eigenvalues
to to the left
and
well it's not difficult to show that
we can
basically um
also basically
the eigenvalues of this matrix s
lie in the following interval so what
i'm saying here is we we can ensure by
tuning beta and gamma
so that the eigenvalues are
strictly negative
and we can also ensure that for instance
like the smallest eigenvalue of a is
smaller than the largest eigenvalue of w
and i just want to just basically
illustrate this quickly so here is like
an arbitrary weight
hidden to hidden matrix we said like
beta 2.5 and gamma 0. so you see like
this matrix um
has eigenvalues
that are
like here positive eigenvalues so
this matrix would like lead to
exploding gradients
but now if we crank up beta a little bit
we squish like the eigenvalues towards
the imaginary axis
and then i can add like a little bit of
gummer here
and shift the eigenvalues so that all
the eigenvalues are negative so in this
case like the dynamics cannot
diverge
then
like
design and choose
as ellipsis
during training time
um okay so here's putting everything
together um basically we just plays like
um a by our
skew symmetric decomposition and w as
well so the disadvantage is that you
have like um addition two additional
tuning or actually four additional
tuning parameters but in practice we see
like these
choosing like these tuning parameters is
um it's not very difficult so for all of
our experiments we use basically the
same tuning parameters
so it works pretty pretty well out of
the box
for new problems
okay and then
again this was like a continuous time
formulation which helped us to analyze
uh what is going on motivate a new
architecture
bake in some structure into into our
neural network and then in order to
train it we we just pick some numerical
scheme
um
for discretization and
in our experiments we choose euler and
aquaphor classic
so let me show you some results that it
actually works
so i'm starting with a simple time
series classification problem basically
you have
sequences or time series from which
belong
which program some belong to class are
and some belong to class b
and then the task is
to
basically classify a new time series
during inference time
um and so here why not using just a
standard feed forward a neural network i
mean the big advantage is with the
recurrent neural networks you can deal
with time series which which have
different um
or varying
lengths
um so that would be difficult to do with
the with the feed forward neural network
um
okay so here are some some results to
show that what we're doing works fine
this is like on the pixel by pixel m
nest
um
[Music]
a
benchmark problem
um and there are two variations we kind
of use the ordered sequence so basically
what you you know you probably all know
amnesty right so you have like a little
thumbnail you flatten it and then you
treat like um
you treat it like as a sequence
basically um and every time t you you um
feed in a pixel at the t's location of
your vector
and then the other option is that you
scramble all the pixels
and work with a permuted sequence so
that really requires the
model to have some memory in order to do
the right classification at the end
and here you see like lstms do not do
very good on the stars particularly not
on the permuted tasks they get just 92
percent uh or 1992.7
accuracy
more modern lstms like the momentum lstm
is doing a little bit better
um
and we get um like with our um
and basically this has 250k
um
parameters
and with about 34k parameters we get
96.3 percent
address r n so indeed this model um it's
easy to train and um it features um or
has some some good expressive
expressivity um and learns like to
memorize important points
um from the past
okay
um
also what what was of interest to us is
to understand whether such a model is
more robust
but here by robustness i mean like more
robust to
some small input perturbations
and here's like a simple plot where we
basically evaluate during inference
times a test accuracy as a function of
amount of
noise that yet i think here we just
added white noise and you can see that
let's lip fits on an out of the box it's
a bit more robust and
for instance the antisymmetric rnn or
other recently proposed on an rnn
architectures
such as the exponential iron in
um or coupled or solitary uh
rnn
and i think like one of the reasons it's
like really that um you you bake in some
um
some
some stability here
uh so you know your model is
is
stable in that way it is
more robust to small input perturbation
but kind of this motivated ascent to do
a bit more work in into this direction
and
led to the formulation of noisy iron
ends and basically the idea is like
generalizing the idea by just
considering an ode we
can also consider a stochastic
differential equation model
for instance we can consider the
following ito sde model here
and kind of where f is
some drift
term and
sigma here is diffusion uh term uh sorry
so it's a bit confusing the sigma here
is not a non-linearity um
but um it's like referring to a
diffusion coefficient
um and then what we do is like we
basically choose for f our lipsticks um
uh the current unit
and uh for sigma
um we we
basically choose some noise model and we
consider here
additive plus multiplicative noise
so we have like in addition like two new
tuning parameters
to
modify like these in noise levels
and if you do this basically what we do
is here is we start with an sde but it
can be viewed like some form of
noise injection
um that we do and that helps us to
improve robustness um what i want to
stress here is we inject noise in in the
latent space not in the input space
right so that's slightly different to
adversarial training
where you
where you add noise in in input space
and kind of that's a simple noise model
we consider here so depending on on your
particular problem you might know what
kind of noise um you deal with so you
can switch out this noise model
and here are some results which i think
are interesting
you can really see that
for
again for white and not a white white
noise
perturbation and salt and pepper noise
perturbation the noisy iron and is
essentially more robust
compared to
the ellipse it's on and then also to
these other iron amps that i showed
before
but um it does not lose some
much performance on on clean data in
case if you don't see any perturbations
and
kind of
the training time is
roughly roughly the same
so in practice right i mean the question
is which which model would you prefer
particularly if you have like a mission
critical application or some medical
application right it's a more robust one
um or it's a less robust one so i would
prefer like a more robust network which
i know is less sensitive to small input
perturbation during inference time
and like using like this sde frameworks
and dwelling too much on theory here but
if you look to the paper you can like
study this neural network through the
lens of stahostic differential equation
and for instance make statements about
implicit regularization
again about stability so kind of this
view
viewing like these neural networks
through the lens of dynamic systems
opens up just a nice tool box
to do some interesting analysis and
understand some nice properties
here's another example where we look
like at electrocardiogram
um
and again it's like a classification
problem
i think we use like here 500 sequences
of length 140 for training and then four
thousand sequences for testing and we
want to classify whether
the heartbeat of a patient
has some severe
heart failure or
whether it's normal
and kind of um our current neural
network is doing a pretty good job to
provide an accurate um
prediction
um so you see like you get 97.7
um accuracy here and again like the
noisy rn
provides you with more robust
predictions even if you have some
perturbations in in the inputs
okay
so here's some some theory about a
regularization but i ask him over this
so if you're interested just have a look
to the paper
or you can drop me an email so i want to
use like the last uh five to
ten minutes um for talking about length
that's our
latest work um
which just appeared at iclr
in in spring
so
what
basically
they are like these two challenges by in
sequence modeling using
neural networks is on the one hand side
you want a model that is very expressive
but you want on the other side also a
model that is able to learn long-term
dependencies
so lstms are known to be very expressive
so that's why they're very popular
um but they are not really good at
learning like long term dependencies
which i showed like before this mnist
pixel to pixel mns where you have a very
long sequence
um and so they say under perform there
but then like
these other models um here particular
like these continuous time models
are not as expressive but they're really
good
at modeling long-term dependencies in
particular unicorn
and corn and they showed example that
they can
deal with sequences up to i think a
length of 18 000 which is extremely long
so that's very impressive so
well what's what kind of um
basically led us to the question how can
we design a new model which is both
expressive but also be able to learn
some long-term dependencies
and
kind of so we asked like what what is
the problem in general with the current
models that we consider and one of the
issues is that like um these ode based
on ends assume a fixed time scale and
that's a pretty strong assumption for
for many
um so many
problems that we deal with
so the idea is kind of to
formulate like
a model which allows to model
many time skills so
it's the simplest case right we could
just start with some
simple or consider a simple system of
two scale odes here
there you have like tau y and tau set
that are kind of able to model two type
skills
um but two time scales is also very
restrictive
uh it's nice to have like the slow and
fast variables here but we can
generalize um this idea so that we can
tackle more more complicated problems
and if we do this we get like this nice
multi-scale version
let's provide it by this following set
of odes here
so here sigma hat is uh now um a sigmoid
um uh function so basically
the values you get here gets squished
between zero and one
so this first block here um
is can be seen at some point as a gate
or kind of modeling these different time
scales
which we then multiply
with the second block where here sigma
is a ton h function
and um
basically that is the um
fast varying or models the fast bearing
vari variables and then we have this
second block here which models the slow
varying
scales
so this is a coupled system
and
again we can discretize the system
using some implicit explicit
timestamping scheme which leads to these
uh following
equations here
um so
if you look at it it looks like a little
bit like an lstm and under certain
conditions there are similarities
we discusses in this paper
and what is nice is like if we study
this discretization here we can show
that
this particular model is mitigating
exploding and vanishing gradients
and we can also show that this model is
a universal approximation of general
dynamical systems
and also like a universal approximation
of multi-scale dynamical systems so it's
a pretty powerful formulation
again motivated by
dynamica system theory
and if i show you some results here
that is like on the google 12 task
um which uh relates a thing that's
that's like post estimation
uh you you can you can see that the lam
is outperforming um
previous models quite quite a bit
so that's like on expressive
expressivity task but it's not that much
better than a
gated recurrent unit
but quite a bit better than lstms
and um
indeed what we want to show here is
better than like these exponential iron
ants or corn and which are known to be
not that expressive
um and that's similar like to um like
some
natural language processing where we try
to predict
some characters in a sentence
and we see like we can greatly improve
the performance using lamps
and
simply the results are more impressive
even on long-term dependency tasks again
um at least compared to lstms so here's
like um a task i could try to do heart
rate prediction again but it's like with
a longer sequence of 4000 so lstm really
do not learn anything meaningful
exponential rnn um
is learning something but it's not
really impressive
and then lem is doing really good on
this task
um and this is like this eigenwarm
problem which considers a very very long
sequence
it's a genomics data set
and we get like some really good
performance compared to other rnn's
so
in summary lem provides like a really
interesting alternative to lstms out of
the box we have also like a high
performance implementation
uh written in cuda so you can just plug
it into
um
into um basically or just use it as a
plug plug plug-in replacement for lstms
and it's nice to see it has now recently
been used or started to being used by by
microsoft
uh for for some uh of their problems so
it gets some some traction
uh it turns out to be
actually useful in a broader range of
applications
here's a quick example like for a
multi-scale system just to basically as
a sanity check i mean do we actually
learn
some interesting multi-scale structure
and here we can see yes so there's an
advantage of of modeling like these
different time scales using lam compared
to other
rnn and lstm models um
sorry what i want to show here is um
[Music]
yeah um
basically what we show here as well is
just an ablation study and the second
plot is like
if you use lamb but you switch off the
multi-scale structure then it does not
learn
really anything meaningful but
if we allow the lamp to learn
multi-skill structure then you get
really good performance
okay perfect i switch over to my summary
so that there is like a little bit of
time for question at the end
um
so
mainly what i uh wanted to present here
is so like motivated success this idea
of ode networks or viewing neural
networks as dynamic systems it's very
useful for many physical
or financial applications where
differential equations are natural
odenets are are good for modeling
irregular sample data that can be done
with
standard discrete time neural networks
and kind of i think exploiting this
connection between dynamic assessment
deep learning um allows us to to develop
more interesting
models that we can better understand and
that also are more robust at the end
i showed like that kind of uh using like
a stochastic differential equation can
be seen as some stahastic learning
strategy and like it's a very simple
trick to improve robustness and that's
like really important in some
[Music]
applications where we know we deal with
noisy data during the first time
okay
i stopped here and
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk ben
very nice very nice um thank you
okay is there any question
from audience and there is no
question in the chat other than robert's
the comments well let's while you guys
think think about it
um
ben can you
go back to
the slide where you talk about lipstick
recurring units sure it seems to be
pretty interesting
um
and by looking at the
you know the formulations
i think here for instance this one
yeah for instance that one and uh can it
be viewed as okay so here you are
designing the right hand side with a
some linear term and yes
non-linear temperature is represented by
neural net yeah
it can be viewed as a
basically it is a dmd um
is
you know the
taking
dmd kind of modeling is taking upon with
the first terms like the linear terms
and the second term is kind of
representing the
error of the dmd
and quantified by the neural net
sure sure i mean you you can probably
have many many interpretations of
viewpoints here right so to be fair
originally my my motivation for this
model so there's like in the control
community there it's like um this class
of lip ships ellipses systems which have
exactly this form like a linear term
plus a non-linear term
and i think it is um
this particular formulation allows you
to
do some global analysis
which you can't just do if you have just
this non-linear term so that was the
motivation here considering this
particular form to
to do this global stability analysis
you can think about in in many ways
about the linear term why you have it
there
um
and
kind of from from from perspective on
like yeah you can say okay there
the linear term is modeling basically
the
linear component and then you have like
the residual which is modeled by the
non-linear term so that's it's different
different uh viewpoints you can
take
sounds good okay um
you know apollo on question um on this
on this um
topic
uh the
next probably next slide or previous
slide do you show the you know
conditions that
the function needs to satisfy like the
licious continuity
yes
and
i i guess not all the available
activation functions satisfy that yeah
that's that's true not not all i am
saying here not not all activations are
m lip sets um but in in some sense i
mean
i mean
most of the times for kernel networks we
use a ton h function
uh which satisfies um this condition i
agree
it's not it's not it's not very popular
or you don't see many other
um activation functions in the
mainstream literature so there are there
are like
some more exotic one like
some modified velo function and it's
used i think in the in the exponential r
and n but uh that typically doesn't work
like in with other architectures so yeah
um
my following question is have you have
you tried with those activation
functions which does not satisfy the
lich's continuity
i see um does it still work i mean
usually the theory and practice
it's it's
okay so one one thing is like of course
i mean this is our i say like um
conditions which needs to be satisfied
in practice i mean we look to the
eigenvalues so we do not um
i mean depending on how you tune it you
can exactly or you can actually
um
kind of meet those conditions but even
if you
don't meet the conditions we show like
we have some ablation studies where we
plot like the eigenvalues of a and w
over time
and
it works surprisingly well if you're
slightly off but then we show also
ablation studies if you
um basically if you choose like beater
here like 0.5 you get really poor
performance
um so we get we have basically a plot
which shows you like um
that
that you want to be somewhat in this
regime here in the middle
or even better here on the right hand
side right but
even if you have a situation where you
do not
satisfy the conditions exactly you still
learn something but if you're too far
away from satisfying the conditions and
suddenly you don't learn anything
anymore so there's a little bit of gap
of
what you see in practice and what you
have in
theory i also want to mention right the
theory holds like for it's a continuous
time formulation but we do the
additional discretization step
right so it depends also a little bit
how how large you choose like your delta
t
for for discretization
yeah so
sometimes we haven't done this i mean we
could do the analysis in discrete times
uh discrete time as well but
uh it was like more like conveying a
point like
having this idea of viewing a
model as a
dynamical systems and then doing doing
doing this analysis and motivating like
basically what was the motivation is
like coming up with this symmetric skew
scheme which turned out to work very
well
all right uh
i shouldn't ask too many questions okay
so there are questions from the uh yes
that room
by andrew he asked for the ecg example
how long did it take to train the neural
network um
so i i don't know so there were like
basically two ones so let's see um i
think like the smaller one
uh which had was
used pretty short sequences i think the
training time there was
uh very fast i think
maybe maybe half an hour or so but for
the second example we considered lamps
um for the hot for the long sequence
that is of the order of days um that's
like really challenging to train
um so
because like as long as the sequence
gets us
it's
painfully slow to train require neural
networks the unicorn model so is very
fast so if you if you look for something
extremely fast for these type of
problems i would recommend to have a
look at the unicorn paper
all right
next question is by rob rap
when you oh
um okay so when you uh look at the
eigenvalues of the matrices being
generated by your neural network are
they close to what you would expect from
a non-linear system analysis standpoint
in other words do you end up generating
stiff differential equations for steep
problems
um
oh i see the second question
yeah that's that's a good good question
so in in some sense like these um mainly
what we done with um iron and
where look to the eigenvalues
i haven't looked to too many
too many
dynamical system problems actually so
here again the idea was like using ideas
from dynamic systems to develop new
neural network architectures um
what i talked about before in in the ode
context that's a good question we i
haven't looked to the eigenvalues there
so basically there we just did this
conversion analysis
so we considered a lot of different
dynamical systems there
and the question was just basically um
does does the model pass the conversion
test or not i haven't looked to
the eigenvalues of neural ode so that's
that's a good question but
uh sadly i can't give a good good answer
to it but something i should probably
investigate
but you do compare the
solution itself not the eigenvalues but
you know say again
you do compare the solution itself like
the solution from the underlying um
yeah
and and your neural or the recovery yeah
that that said we do i i just don't know
like um again i think we have considered
stiff systems there
um
i think the um normally a pendulum in
the x y was uh x y coordinates that's
very stiff
um and what we see in general it's
harder to train these problems but i'm
not exactly sure how the eigenvalues
look like well i think if you go back to
the beginning where you're showing some
of your plots comparing the numerical
oilers
to what the network is producing like
here's a case where euler's going crazy
due to stiffness yeah yeah and um the
neural network is doing just fine
yeah so
i what i suspect you will find is that
um
you don't have the stiffness that you
would expect to have
yeah in the integrator just looking at
this plot and looking at the plots there
on the right
and i think it'd be really interesting
because i think what your neural network
is actually doing if you plug in the
text
time step it's actually solving both
the
[Music]
numerical it's solving the right hand
side and coming up with like a
specialized integrator for that problem
yeah
i i guess so so that's my point right
it's it's it's learning through the
through the integrator um through right
so it comes up with something in some
sense right with you if you use forward
sometimes basically if you use forward
euler you have no inductive buyers
um doing the training process with arka4
if you use like boxes more complicated
schemes so you give the room you
introduce some inductive buyers and you
give like the
model less room to learn something
outside of the scheme
i i would be super interested if you say
try to teach
one of these neural networks on
continuity
so like take a problem where you have
the analytical solution right yeah and
then
just very time step wildly
um and plug in the analytical
analytical solution and see if you can
actually come up with a
and have the um the time step be one of
the parameters
for your sequence
and then see if you can develop a
network that can integrate
this thing in a stable manner no matter
what the time step is because i mean as
from a neural networks uh from like a
sequence training point of view that's
not super useful but from a numerical
methods point of view
that's extremely interesting yeah
yeah maybe we should touch base offline
and
talk a bit about those ideas i think
that would be great okay cool
rob i have a question for you how wild
time step variation are you thinking
here
as well as you want
all right basically just enough to kind
of teach the model continuity and
sometimes i would like deliberately plug
in like a time step of zero
um just so it like hand handles the
limit condition
um but you kind of want to teach the
model how to converge right because i
mean the big problem i'm seeing with the
when you do convergence on the neural
network you train at different time
steps it doesn't seem to be converging
but i think you can train a neural
network how to converge
by varying the time step because i mean
that's the constraint that we put on
numerical systems and we know that they
can do it so
it'd be really interesting to see if the
neural network could find those
all right sounds good
is there any other questions
we passed the six minutes actually the
promised time um well uh
if not let's thank our speaker ben for
the wonderful talk um i personally enjoy
it a lot and i learned a lot from it
from the talk and yeah and it's a
wonderful job and
i'm sure
um there will be uh full future
collaboration
yeah thank you so much for the
invitation again it was great
awesome awesome
all right let me stop the recording